so today this is exciting we're going to
do a literature review i don't do a lot
of these
um because uh i'm barely literate
so you know but but this is literature
that i can handle
uh it's a children's book so uh we've
got the anti-racist
baby by ibram x kendi that's the book
we're going to be reviewing today
and i can tell you up front this is not
a parody
uh this book is is real these are real
recommendations
for how to make sure that your babies
are anti-racist
so i thought and i thought you know i
saw this i thought it'd be a good thing
for me to
to read as a as a parent i've got four
kids
the only problem is that three of my
kids are a little bit older now they're
not babies anymore
and so i'm worried that this book came
along too late
and it's too late to make them
anti-racist they're you know they're
already nazis basically they're a lost
cause i can't do anything about it
but my my youngest child is one is one
she's one year old
and so it might not be too late to make
her an anti-racist baby she's already
got
some nazi tendencies i have to admit
like the way she waves
is a little suspicious a little bit of a
nazi salute-esque wave
um so i think now there could be a
better time for me to read this book and
find out
how to how to have anti-racist babies so
we'll go through this
okay says anti-racist baby is bread
not born anti-racist baby is raised to
make
society transform i have to agree
you know people are not born as woke
leftist lunatics
you have to brainwash them so that's
what it means here when he says
when he says bread not born they mean
the baby is not born but brainwashed
that's what's meant just to be clear
babies are taught to be racist or
anti-racist there's no neutrality
take these nine steps to make equity a
reality
the main thing i'm focused on here is
the picture
what kind of baby is this this baby is
650 pounds
wearing a loincloth the authors of this
book as expected
have never actually been around a baby
so i'm already sensing there's a problem
here
they don't know what a baby looks like
they were they were trying to draw a
picture of a baby and they said
huh baby babies what are those they they
look kind of like roman emperors right
let's keep going all right number one
open your eyes to all skin colors
anti-racist baby learns all the colors
not because race is true
wait what anti-racist baby learns all
the colors
not because race is true if you claim to
be colorblind
you deny what's right in front of you
all right i don't mean to get hung up on
the pictures again here
but what is the guy here
with the guy with the dog what is he
wearing he looks to be wearing like a
jumpsuit with paint splattered all over
it what is that
so he was painting a house i guess but
then he's also wearing high heel boots
he was painting a house in high-heeled
boots
and here they're carrying massive like
mutant carrots so i have no idea
what's going on in this picture but i'm
already quite disturbed
we'll keep going number two use your
words to talk about race
no one will see racism if we only stay
silent
if we don't name racism it won't stop
being so
violent now this is good advice
use your words right very good advice um
the blm writers and looters could have
taken that advice
unless by you know when they say use
your words to talk about race what they
mean is
burn down a cvs it's not exactly clear
number three
point at policies as the problem not
people
some people get more while others get
less because policies don't always grant
equal access yeah this is good advice to
give a baby
um i know that i'm always telling our
kids
starting when they're infants that they
need to focus more on government
policies
i'm always saying that to them i'm
always saying it's about the policies
it's always a proud moment for for a
parent when your child
uh first cites their you know recites
their first governmental policy
so i'll never forget when my daughter uh
two years old first mentioned the
personal responsibility and work
opportunity reconciliation act of 1996
and pointed out how it stigmatizes
disadvantaged peoples
that was a very proud moment for me um
and of course the other great thing is
that
you want to train your children to blame
everything on
policies and environment and the
situation
and really anything other than their own
behavior because that's what's being
said here that's another thing i'm
always telling my kids like any parent
i'm always saying remember
never take responsibility for anything
important lesson to learn let's see
we're on number four
shout there's nothing wrong with the
people
even though all races are not treated
the same we are all human
anti-racist baby can proclaim
notice here on the uh on the we're all
human page
okay we're all human now we get pictures
of all different kinds of people
there's no white man on the we're all
human page that is not a coincidence
the only white person is a lesbian woman
again
uh not not a coincidence okay number
five celebrate all of our differences
anti-racist baby doesn't see certain
groups as better or worse anti-racist
baby loves a world that's truly diverse
no races are better or worse right uh i
mean
it's almost like you're saying i don't
know
all lives matter but you can't say that
that's racist of course we can't say
that number six
knock down the stack of cultural blocks
anti-racist baby appreciates how groups
speak dance and create as they choose
anti-racist baby welcomes all groups
voicing their unique
views right but you better not
appreciate
other groups by taking part in their
cultural traditions or
borrowing or adapting their traditions
because that's appropriation and if you
do that you are literally hitler
number seven confess when being racist
nothing disrupts racism more than
when we confess the racist ideas that we
sometimes
express another crucial lesson for
children you know confess when you're
racist i can tell you for my children in
my family
uh we end each day by confessing our
racism the tradition we have we all
stand up we take terms
standing up in the living room
confessing the racist thoughts we had
that day the racist things we had we
said
did that day and then other family
members will throw
rocks and glass bottles at us so it's
just sort of a fun and wholesome
tradition
and i think it teaches the kids the
right lessons number eight
grow to be an anti-racist anti-racist
baby is always learning and changing and
growing
anti-racist baby stays curious about all
people
and isn't all knowing now this one
actually does look a little bit like my
house
different skin tone different fashion
sense but you've got one kid
peeking out from the corner another kid
behind the couch
like a kid hanging from a ceiling you've
got a kid dancing some weird dance in
the middle of the living room
so this part is relatable this is what
my house is like this part i understand
at least this is the only part i
understand
nine believe we shall overcome racism
anti-racist baby is filled with the
power to transcend my friend
and doesn't judge a book by its cover
but reads until
the end great lesson but the problem is
we can't overcome racism can we because
white people
are inherently racist you will always be
racist they don't tell you that part
right
until you've already been indoctrinated
into the cult so they get you there by
by promising to heal your racism
and then they say oh you know become an
anti-racist and you won't you will
he'll heal your racism and then you join
and they say actually never mind
the secret is that you will never not be
racist but what we can promise you
instead is plenty of scorn resentment
and guilt
laid at your feet and that is one hell
of a way to parent